припис між рядовим актом про
здачу приймання технічної допомоги
завершена там двостороння фітнес
україну та китайську народну республіку
новим результатом праці 2 краєм для віч
вади гозіас вигляд і стала гуманітарно
допомога вид кнр про вигоду комп'ютерна
техніка
між керівниками двох держав
була досягнута домовленість про те, що
китайська народна республіка надає
допомога Україні для розвитку гуманітарної
сфери
після цього уряд України
провело кілька внутрішніх процедур та
було ухвалено рішення кабінету міністрів
України
що ця допомога буде надана ми
буде спрямована на розвиток середнього
освіти треба маму наварити близько
двох із половиною тисяч українських
шпинату і мало комп'ютерних класу мене
пасти
удар він до вигляду КНР так нікуди україни
доставили 3 гігантськими такі два поверхи
180 тонн шкір у церкви 2012 року так
українській школі ріо при молоді та 23
тисяч китайських комп'ютерів на суму
близько 12 мільйонів доларів США
одразу передав і до керування свято
всіх областей та автономної республіки
крим комп'ютерів стану це протестував і
до початку початкову гаракуту ж поспішаючи
виріс на жку дареджан
курей злякалася хмарами одягу мені паші
ровані правдиву інформацію протягнутися
комп'ютери не буду надати не для
нігтями вона чітко і без простого не
стеж за це представник 2 краєм у
столичну спеціалізовану школу
перспектива потрібна 194 деякі
журналісти не розібравшись, намагалися
говорити про те, що техніка не підходить і
є проблеми ми одразу з паном
послом разом поїхали до звичайної школи не
у центрі міста було не саме і
подивилися хлопців 8 клас кожен зробив
індивідуальну програму англійською
українською та деякі навіть іноді
китайською китайською мовою мені дуже
сподобалося побачити усмішкою лісах
у юних школярів друзів я радий що
китайська комп'ютерна техніка по gravis
українським школярам з перебитими ж
світячи нам і 2 краєм триває
розвивається практика обміну студентами
закладу чами та професором та тарик 200
українських дітей побували на китайських
курортах а сто наших студентів від романи
Степан david КНР цього року ми також на
чиї продовжимо таку практику як
унітарної допомоги якщо вона потрібна і будемо
почати працювати спільно, щоб громадяни
китаю та україни
weasel обмацали конкретний результатів від
нашої з вами спільної роботи
партнерство між вам околицях і набираючи
звернувши спів процесу до середніх
проектів став та show dance наприклад
між рядами їх зносу